hello welcome to EE 380 the Stanford
electrical engineering department
colloquium on computer systems our
speaker today is Stephen Pugh Stephen is
a founder and CEO of tax era and he's
going to be speaking today on practical
blockchain applications Steve all right
thank you very much Dennis so my name is
Stephen and and I hope everyone is
keeping safe and healthy getting to
spend Emily so today we're going to talk
a little bit about practical blocking
applications with an emphasis on
practical because blocking is such a new
technology I think the entire space is
really searching for a large-scale
mainstream applications upon which this
technology can be effectively deployed
all right so let's dig into it so first
I'm gonna give a brief introduction okay
so the project's name is dr. access so
we're a public ledger that's you know
focused on streamlining operational
processes and micro agreements were
founded in 2018 by a few guys from
Stanford were fully distributed team in
Silicon Valley
Tokyo Shanghai Ukraine and a few other
places a little bit about myself I was
not renewing wireless sensor networks
and mobile health I was most recently a
strategy consultant associate partner
and monitored Illinois advising large
companies in digital strategy and and I
was the graduate of Stanford seee
Department okay so a little bit about
what you expect from today's talk the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to share our learnings right so
because this is such a new field and
things are changing every day we are
going to share with you our journey
being in our attempt right you find
real-world applications right actually
solve commercial problems so the second
thing is that this talk is going to be
very very application focused once again
the reason is to be focusing there you
know previous few years the emphasis has
been largely on the core tech
oh gee but you know a lot of the
technology has been built and now
everyone is looking for application so
this couldn't be an application for this
top the third one is that this is not
going to be a very technical heavy talk
it will stream some understanding basic
understanding distributed systems in
cryptography but not a lot if you have
any questions about the technical nature
of our blocking or applications
you know happy to answer them during Q&A
or you know send me a message over
twitter or or Mikey all right that's
fine
happy to uh engage us in discussions
okay so the first step what can block
chain technology actually do right so
because blocking is such a new
technology right so the first thing that
we needed to do as a start-up in
addition to actually building the
technology building this public chain we
actually need to understand what they
can do and when it cannot be right so
then we can try to fit in an into
actually problems that we see in the
real world all right so there are lots
of definitions on what blocking is here
I'm going to present our definition very
simple we think blocking system does
three things right it allows entities
should actually commit statements right
so blocking allows entities to commit
hard to fake easy value statements this
is not new it's just asymmetric
cryptography so it's been around for a
long time the technology's been around
for a while right that's its feature
number one feature number two it allows
entities to agree on a version of
reality right so there are these rules
they're called consensus algorithms on
launching systems that allows nodes to
come together and agree on this is what
reality means for our network at this
given height right there are lots of
different types of consent algorithms so
a classic one might be what you see on
Bitcoin there called the Nakamoto
consensus which favors lionesses over
safety in that the network always makes
progress but it could be a fork later
into a different version of reality
right and then you have these Gbit
algorithms which favors safety over
lightness so the network is for example
partition
the network adjusting highly stop
because this it's not going to produce a
block if you know hasn't reached a
certain center quorum threshold right so
whatever consensus algorithm is used
allows network to agree on reality and
the third characteristic is that it
allows replication of records right so
every single node a full node actually
has a full state replication of
everything that's ever happened right
not only does it replicate director it's
actually process of the records too
right so these three things right
they're based on technology that are not
reading you so as you can see a lot of
these technologies that already in
existence long before brought thinking
long but they've been put together in
this interesting way right and actually
produce some interesting properties
so what blocking system produces is that
as a set of immutable ordered
commitments right so an immutable part
of it comes from the fact that you know
every single know has a compliment okay
so in order for you to really change the
record you got to change a law with
these records you got to change it all
these nodes or a bride with all these
nodes or crop block these notes which
are very hard to do especially
considering that they're controlled by
disparate entities with no not
necessarily any overlapping interests we
have ordered as this comes from the
agreement on reality right because part
of the agreement on reality is that you
have to have seen slew the correct order
right and commitments of course comes
from the asymmetric cryptography so
immutable order commitments you know
very sound simple but it actually does
not interesting things okay so the next
thing to really think about is okay so
we now know what boxing is what it can
do you know but what are some of its
characteristics or limitations right
there has very critical implications on
applications right so once again there
are lots of these definitions out there
you can find in the web they're actually
also a very sophisticated decision trees
that people have constructed to help to
help potential technologists or
application creators to figure out
whether or not they need a bug here we
list three characteristics we think are
actually very very critical
in their implication on the potential
application what the application should
look like so the first one is that
blocking systems are very slow very slow
compared to you centralized system so
these central systems not surprisingly
always slower than centralized systems
right so what does that mean that means
is that you know you should not really
try to replace decent centralized
systems completely with these ecosystems
if you do that you're gonna get very
very very poor performance right so
during the early days of a buffing
application development you see for
example there was an application that
allow people to play poker right and
every single participant had to you know
do this commit and reveal scheme on the
bar chain very secure and nobody could
see is great
it took three minutes to shuffle a deck
right so well it's great that you
couldn't cheat are you really gonna sit
around and wait three minutes every time
it's in your deck a shot I'm not really
so performance not great I second right
blockchain has very different guarantees
depending on the type of data that
you're using right so this really comes
from this your misconception I know
they're books and articles lots of stuff
out there that right um you know that
the state of auctioning is this truth
machine or a single point of truth right
so you know actually blocking is not
that good at guaranteeing truth right it
has the same garbage in garbage out
problem that you know pretty much all
systems have it really only guarantees
veracity when the data is wholly
originated and self contained within the
ecosystem which in the case of
cryptocurrencies it is but once again
cryptocurrency accounts for a tiny
negligible fraction the data in our
world so the vast majority time you for
getting with things that are outside the
blockchain
you cannot rely on it for veracity right
the third thing is that blushing is very
complex
right it's super complex you understand
and you definitely definitely definitely
don't long to expose that complexity to
the end-user right if you go to your
potential customer and you start talking
about consensus Albert
and private keys chances are that
customer is gone you know within five
minutes right so you must find ways to
make rational reasonable compromises to
hide the complexity from the end users
or else you're never going to reach why
stripe adoption right for any of your
applications okay so let's go through
these one by one right so first of all
blocking is slow right and these tree
blocking is slow right so what makes
walking slow well there are lots of
reasons why blocking is slow here are
several first we talk about full state
replication and execution so every full
node has a copy of everything that has
happened on the boxing and must execute
through every single thing every single
transaction on the box right so there
are some recent advances you know with
zero knowledge proves where people can
have shorter proofs but the fundamental
principle is still the same in that each
phone note in order to remain trustless
and guarantee immutability they need to
have a copy of everything right so that
right away is a lot of redundant space
redundant processing power and you have
to deal with a second thing is that you
know there's a lot of redundant gossip
happening over the network right so if
you're a full node on the network and
you're connected to you like you know 10
20 other nodes there's a good chance
that every single thing that has
happened on a network you'll hear about
it like 20 times or more right and
that's actually you know a feature it's
a security feature right because for no
to remain trustless it can't risk having
you know that one you know know that
that one appear that you're connected to
becoming corrupted or becoming malicious
and then you becoming corrupted by
extension right so hearing a lot of
redundant gossip is a good idea because
then you have lots of things to check
against it right but it's not very
efficient right once again it's not very
efficient and true once again true
decentralized barching networks you
typically have a unstructured
peer-to-peer network right so you cannot
make presumptions about who's in who's
out where they are Layton sees so none
of these things have guarantees right so
you just have to trust that
this sort of very redundant asset is
going to keep you trust us but very
inefficient the third one is far as
waiting for agreement right so every set
of transactions need to be seen an
agreed upon through some rule right and
that rule can be fast everything is so
but regardless you have to wait for it
right so you have to wait for so all
these things make washing systems very
slow right so what's the implications on
example implication once again is that
you know you really want to use these
central systems like boxing to bolster
sentences not to replace them right so
for example centralized system here
central systems are very mature they're
very efficient you know they have very
clear legal responsibilities but they do
have this one critical flaw which is
that they can cheat right they can cheat
without you knowing or anyone else know
so really the goal should be you know
working on trying to take advantage the
best of both worlds is to make sure that
you use the d central system to ensure
that central systems cannot cheat if
you've achieved a goal you have
effectively that gotten the best of both
worlds you've gotten the efficiencies of
centralized systems and you've kept them
honest all right so this is a really
really I think critical point because so
many applications towards the beginning
of this technological movement just
outright move entire application stacks
onto the bottom which resulted in some
very very important user experiences
okay so the second thing you know
different types of data have different
guarantees so roughly in this very
unscientific chart on the side I'm
trying to demonstrate sort of the
relative sizes of different types of
data so we can write data into three
categories right one type a is dated us
to get a generated on the change so this
is something like your cryptocurrency or
your bitcoins or etherion coins these
are these are data that's being
generated on the chain right second
right the second type of data is data
that's being generated off chain right
but it's actually publicly known data
lots of people know about it
so this type of data could be things
like weather things that you know did
you know the outcome of sports events
things like that right so this is option
data but known to many and then you have
the third fine right type C generator
off chain but known to a few this is the
vast majority of data in the world in
which only a few people or a few
entities are privy to the data for
example you know my company's financial
records my operational records the fact
that I got in a car accident would build
a state I mean these are things that
only a few people know so there are
three types of data right with you know
the third typing the the most numerous
the most voluminous so when we talk
about you know blotching as the you know
as has guaranteed some truth it has
guarantees on veracity really only the
first type of data has that guarantee
right you get guarantees on Providence
where the data came from he guarantees
immutability it has an intent forward
and you get this critical guarantee of
veracity that it happened is true is
actually the right is actually true all
right you only really get that for type
a and it's a tiny bit of data right for
type B you have data that's generated
off chain known to many because sort of
you know get by with the maratha
guarantee by using by using these games
right so for example you have you have
platforms like all girl your platforms
like chaining
what do you do is that you know they
take publicly known data and you know
they have data providers they're
randomly selected to provide you data by
the same kind of data Watchers on the
side who actually watched the data
that's being provided and they can they
can expose you if you're coming you know
cutting falsehoods right if you're
providing raw data and making explosive
so it's basically a vote
English if you have lots of these
Watchers saying that you're wrong right
then you get fine you know very heavily
and it's not worth it for you to get
fine alright so it's really it's really
through this kind of game mechanism
where you have some guarantee over ass
right but for the vast majority of data
right that's in this world today you
don't get any veracity guarantees
that's once again garbage in garbage on
you don't know what people or entities
or machines are uploaded right but
what's very interesting here is that um
just with provenance and immutability
just those two guarantees are actually
very very very useful right a lot of
people will think wow if you have no
veracity guarantee then or everything is
out the window
this is completely useless well no not
really right so you know let's look at a
simple example right so this example
actually King this example is actually a
tiny example now I'll tell you about the
story that was inspired this example
right so very interesting um here you
have a hypothetical you know supply
chain data collection example right so
you have lots of people and all the
supply chain manufacturers shippers
storage people retailer and customer
they're all sort of hashing their data
and creating to the boxing right is
great but of course you get garbage in
garbage out there's no guarantee that
any of these people or entities are
uploading correct data right true data
right but it doesn't matter right the
reason why it doesn't matter is that you
still know who entered that data you
know that that data was in tampered with
after it was injured so you can trace
responsibility right so the point here
is that you can track responsibility not
truth and here's the interesting story
right interesting story is that a few
years ago this is actually even before
boxing even came into my mind our field
of vision I was actually you know
talking to this official from the
Chinese agricultural ministry very very
interesting so he was talking about food
safety and how there are lots of food
safety issues and they've always wanted
to construct a system in which everyone
uploaded every single you know chain of
the food food supply ecosystem right
into their centralized system and I said
well what if he were entered wrong data
right and he said well I don't care
people in true-false state right it
doesn't matter to me what they did to
injure as long as they claimed
responsibility for a specific segment of
the food right so this example is very
simple it's very interesting he said if
someone got sick eating an apple from a
supermarket today it would take me
months to track down who was responsible
who was he
in a shipment of apples right and by the
time I start my investigation you know
took a few weeks you know the news that
would leaked out and other people that
were responsible with a change of
records already and I would never find
right that's a big problem right he said
that if we had a system in which
everyone you know registered and upload
their data I don't really know where the
problem is but I can quickly you know
zooming and say hey the problem is with
these 20 companies right he said I could
have to pleat this can't happen in the
u.s. obviously but it can happen in
China potentially you have to police
round up the CEOs of all these 20
companies and put them in a room and say
hey I don't know what happened right but
somebody here screwed up that maybe
wasn't you maybe many of you right and
we're now going to exit this room until
we figure out what happened right so
once again right it's sort of an extreme
it's very interesting example but it
tells you that just the ability she
tracked responsibility right is actually
really powerful right he can solve a lot
of problems you don't care that the data
is correct or not so that's the second
example so the third one right once
again you know blocking is complex so
you got a trick you hide attack come on
right you can't really tell the end-user
a lot about the technology because that
just confuses them and scare some away
right so you know instead of saying
things like trust us you say confidence
I mean so seeing things immutable is
just secure append-only you say
auditable right decent rise is a
transparent right so you use a lot of
these words and actually talk about the
benefits of the technology instead of
the feature themselves right and once
again one of the critical examples that
we have is is we got a hide the key I
think that the secret key is the bane
right really the bank towards adoption
right so if the data source is a piece
of hardware for example we have a use
case later which we'll talk about then
you should really be creating secure
hardware that actually generates and
hold the piece on the hardware right
don't get the user or the owner
to deal with these keys they should not
it may do introduces a common complexity
right if the user is a person you can do
something like use the password
encrypted backup right and of the secret
key store the secret key locally if
somehow they lose it you can you know
give them a password encrypted backup if
they lose the password you can
potentially reassociate a new private
and public key pair through social
validation for example right and this is
the this is the case when there's no
assets in law right where you don't
actually even care about the key listed
it doesn't really stop taking the assets
now if there are assets look right for
example if the user or person and
they're managing you know cryptocurrency
assets and where the key cannot be lost
right so in that case you want to go
with you know hardware and multi
signature solutions for example with
with also hardware recovery keys of a
master key that generates other keys so
you want to once again hide the key
right you don't want to get the user
just directly interact with a key that's
just a bad idea so I think we've all
seen applications decentralized
applications English right when you open
the application
what are you asked to do you're asked to
write down a secret key and you're told
running down a piece of paper don't lose
it if you lose it everything is lost
forever no one can help you right so
that kind of user experience is
guaranteed to lose you almost all your
users
all right so hide the key that's another
very critical example right so these are
some of the lessons that we've learned
by interacting with lots of customers
and potential customers with regard to
you know what can botching technology do
Christ so so next we're going to talk
about you know our journey in our in
seeking a real world practical
application right you really deploy this
interesting new technology so what is
our what is our goal here right so so
our goal is actually you know pretty
pretty you know pretty all daesh's I
would say right to help modern
enterprise
is scale and adapt efficiently to
today's rapidly changing mother right
this actually comes from experiences
that I've had
running startups as far as my
experiencing advice large corporations
right so once again nothing's written on
this page is any first anything
earth-shattering right as you scale as a
enterprise from startup in to
multinational right you you actually
lose a lot of the characteristics that
made you successful to begin with right
so startups you know they're
inexperienced they're you don't have
money you know they're building
everything from scratch but they have
the advantages of being very fast and
very responsive very very responsive to
the markets changing demands right as
you start scaling up into a
multinational you have like ten layers
of reporting structure between the CEO
and you know whoever the lowest kind of
run this then you start losing all of
those advantages
all right you start losing other you
become very slow multi-layered and you
know God forbid becomes very political
right in these organizations well but
really the problem here is coordination
right so organizations need to
coordinate in order to achieve you know
projects right and because our
technology has only gotten more and more
complex over time you know within our
civilization it only gets more complexed
to be able to build projects you need to
coordinate with ever more resources
right which usually requires
coordinating a lot more people a lot of
different entities right so that
coronation conscious keeps on going up
you know keeps on going up and in as it
goes up to a certain point you have
these companies that are just destined
to die right because they can not adapt
right you the changing world so how do
we how do we change them right so how
can we help to break this trader right
because I can imagine very soon it
perhaps in my lifetime where technology
is changing so fast and becoming so
complex that large organizations become
completely frozen right because they are
constantly making incorrect decisions
so how do we probably heard how do we
address their problem well you know
blockchain could be a potentially
interesting technology can to break this
trade off because it allows trustus
collaboration trusts coordination right
so what does that mean when you
translate into actual real terms well
this gives you sort of our journey
writing terms of trying to find a
practical starting from the practical
entry point into solving this problem so
we had a lot of false starts as most
startups do you know we're looking at
IOT data markets mobile bandwidth
sharing decentralized certificate
authorities anonymized IOT data
gathering there are all these things
that we did they were either too big or
bottom wasn't really a good fit
you know variety of issues we didn't
really start hitting you know the nail
on the head until really second half of
2019 so second half of last year right
when we started finding applications
where blockchain is uniquely positioned
you actually solved the problem and that
really got us on this path of you know
helping corporations were helping
enterprises collect high confidence
operational process data right so let's
go through some of these examples and
why I find them so interesting so the
first one is it's actually an asset
leasing example right the asset here
being arcane machines so the customers
the Japanese consumer they've been
leasing arcades in Japan for 34 years
right
very well-known company they started
expanding their markets overseas and
into Asia and Southeast Asia and East
Asia in Southeast Asia
there's a ton of demand in the market
they're working on a model profit
sharing as a revenue sharing model right
busy however much the money this machine
is or any they get a color that right
now the problem that they run into is
that they cannot get into an agreement
with their customers as well as their
ecosystem stakeholders right exactly how
much this machine is or any because
remember the Machine they're leasing is
somewhere else where they can't see it
right now the simple problem the simple
solution now why don't we just put a
sensor on right
right put a sensor on it and it'll just
report back how much is earning well I
mean that's a problem because their
partners will say well how do I know you
know that data comes from a sensor how
would I know that right how do I know
they just make it up it's one of these
classic cases you know it's not that I
don't trust you but I don't trust you
you know that kind of thing
so they were stuck with over 20,000
orders on her hand which they don't want
to fulfill all right because they know
that you know they'll lose money if they
give forcing to a fixed fee MA
right so what did they do right so our
solution is actually quite simple so
first of all you know you still go with
the identity idea right you put a sensor
on the machine that detects coin tickets
as well as the several current signals
then actually goes into the operation of
the Machine and you give a feedback on
the status of the Machine how many coins
guy inserted how many tickets that spit
out what are the machines running all
right pretty simple the the key
difference here is that there's two key
differences right first of all in
addition to uploading this data into the
cloud as usual in its periodic key
hashing the entire dataset is collected
for like the past six hours signing it
and opening angel boxing so it's
creating an audit lock okay the second
thing is special about this this
dissolution is that the hardware itself
is made to be tempered right so there's
a secure element on there that's you
know modernists amateur technology and
all the credit cards that generates in
science a journalist you know the
private key in a sense everything with
the private key with no way for outside
parties you actually read or an
ultra-right and the business logic is
actually encoded into a MCU where it's
took your boot and after we entered the
business logic we actually just disabled
the updating capability so that
basically the MCU becomes completely
tamper proof as well all right so in
fact this piece of hardware that's you
know almost basically impossible to
tamper with in remotely or locally that
that operates long way and one way only
right that's actually putting up data
into the cloud at the same time
anchoring our data independently engine
abolishing right so later on you can
actually do an audit right and what does
that all day guarantee like we talked
about before it guarantees data
provenance and their guarantees data
immutability right you know exactly
where that data comes from right because
there's that signature on there which is
now fake of all because it was generated
on the module and what stall didn't
Internet private private key injury and
you also know that it was it was
immutable it wasn't helpful with because
once again it was hashed put in a
blockchain not temper right so what that
does is that it helps these party she
drives some baseline consensus right
you're like okay fine we all know each
other we're doing business together at
least we can agree on the operational
status these machines right from this
data right so that actually really helps
them to expand your market right
otherwise they have a very very
difficult time leasing these machines to
parties that hitherto haven't worked
right so this is the leasing application
very interesting the second example is
sort of like an extension the first
example from English we're working with
women the largest automakers in Japan
and they were also interested in
exploring what Boston can do for for
cars right so we brainstorm any ideas
and we're starting to implement a few of
those but one of the things that we
started thinking about very very we
thought it was very interesting is this
idea of used-car trading right so
whenever you buy a used car at least in
the u.s. right you you're also need
effective you paying for this CARFAX
report which costs 40 bucks right so
when I'm buying a used car and other
people but when I'm buying a used car
really really worried about two things
mileage and accidents right whatnots
been an accident
and that's really what the CARFAX report
does for you right a house you can
validate my attention and they drastic I
mean so first of all you know it's 40
bus which you know I would like not to
pay 40 bucks second of all there's
really no awake independently verified
information as on each reports right so
a company like Carfax collects the data
from a purchase the data from lots of
insurance and companies and car repair
shops and our guests today are using
their own secret proprietary algorithm
which you cannot check and in it costs
40 bucks right so what's three what's
really a good solution right so once
again if you install this the same
secure hardware module into each vehicle
right the two sensors didn't care about
our odometer and accelerometer right so
if you can actually anchor odometer and
accelerometer data into the boxing it
has to sink to the bottom right you can
later on provide a report that's
auditable where you can actually say hey
i know exactly how many miles this car
has traveled and i recorded a whole
major impact events because they're
recorded by the accelerometer right so
that report can be provided to chew a
potential buyers of used vehicles at
almost no cost right because this is not
a company buying data from lots of
different other companies this is just a
data that's being generated by the car
on its own right um so it was again you
know you have a much cheaper and far
more accurate option right in order to
prove the history of a used vehicle
right so here we have a third a third
use case which you know really gets very
very close when I treat the
organizational coordination problem that
we set out to release resolve so we're
looking at the construction industry are
in a US rice specifically looking at
construction subcontractors
so a la construction job site you know
what happens is that every single day no
matter if it's a small site is a small
job or a big job you had multiple sent
tens of you know or up to a hundred of
you know changes that actually happened
on a job site you certainly change your
site you know the colonies to change the
wind on you to move to the side like by
half an inch or whatever there's tons
these little changes and these changes
are usually communicated you know
instructor weights or text verbal email
right I mean and you so just
communicated will agree on it and and
they move on to you know keep working on
their job right the problem is that you
know a lot of these informal agreements
right um they need you are in each
disputes right so most of time these
disputes or just for doesn't really
matter
maybe it'll cost like you know one day
cost a few thousand bucks all right no
one's gonna really go you know go to
court on that but these things really
pile up right so if you kind of not see
slow no pinpricks of disputes what ends
up happening is that you you delay the
job by mini days and that's a lot of
cost they could also teach you
litigation right so the solution to this
once again is to use you know to use the
blocks which you actually build an audit
trail these micro agreements right so
these participants he stakeholders can
actually just stay within whatever tool
that they like to use um and they could
anchor these uh these agreements right
by cryptographic assigning them just
click a button you sign it and against
alcohol into the boxing so later on
these things can be audited right so if
there are any so disputes about who said
what when you actually get this is a
perfectly audible trail of what actually
happened all right so this Grady helps
you lose today and minimize disputes
okay so um we've talked about you know
the technology application fit you know
we talked about our application seeking
journey so next that we've been talking
about you know where some of the things
that were actually building right so so
to sum it all up right so the problem
that we're actually solving right now
with the application path from network
building is really trying to resolve
this problem of that knowledge and
confidence cows limits Katie right so
you know the modern enterprise today
given the rapid changing market we want
to be as data-driven as possible right a
lot of times you actually want
operational real-time operational data
he said you know lagging indicators I
find
right so you know what they let you cry
how to collect the data and how to act
on that right so the problem that we're
really trying to solve is the second
part which is how to collect that data
right so data work once again first law
is very difficult to collect and once
you collect it it's actually you know
it's actually harder to believe that
it's more difficult to believe so what
is really driving these problems right
so hard to collect right that's really
driven by the fact that you know most of
the world's operational data right
process data is actually unstructured
right we had this report that came out a
box that just said that you know over
80% of operational process data in this
world or unstructured they happen over
text email right unstructured
information very difficult to find very
few people are willing to use highly
structured ways to enter data like the
ERP systems for project management
systems of you have today all right so
hard to collect the data even when you
do collect the data the data is you know
very hard to believe because you know
people have no confidence in that data I
done so many strategy projects where the
executives of these enterprises
straight-up tell me that the data in our
ERP systems are not to be trusted
right it's very simple it's because
these systems do not react and change in
a damn quick enough to market conditions
so ends up happening is that the people
who are entering them their partners and
their employees for example they would
just enter some whatever data they want
to enter to make sure they meet their KP
us and they're not going to risk the
loss of business you know in favor of
spending time structuring data correct
right so this really limits the
enterprise's ability to streamline to
innovate to forecast to comply with
regulations and also to scale right so
what is unique about this type of
application that we're building right so
we're working at a two axis right we're
looking at the confidence in the data
that you're collecting how much
confidence you have ridges how much time
and expense you expending on getting
that data right so you know at the lower
left corner
the most informal and the least
confident of data types which is a
casual conversation for example right
how the kind of conversation you agreed
on something right well that's not very
confident because no one's there to
witness it or sign eating but it costs a
little part right so if you migrate over
you spend a lot more time and experience
you gain more confidence in getting to
nice ERP systems and project management
software ok right so you know but as
we've seen so far
you know most that data Enterprise are
not really that trusted right people
think that it's a lil D and therefore
they just enter whatever right so this
is this is only data that's for internal
consumption right as soon as we get into
an external world for example you share
this data with external auditors you
share this data with financial
institutions you need to start getting
other people outside your company to
believe this data well then then the
price goes way up right
you gotta get you know professional
services companies to come into
commercial due diligence you got to get
like the financial auditors or you know
the ultimate you know costly thing but
it's really the final verdict on
everything with litigation right so this
is what we have today right this is what
we have today in terms of how costly it
is to collect operational data and how
much confidence you have operational
either with a big confidence gap in the
middle right when you go from external
consumption internal consumption of the
state energy external consumption
alright so when we're trying to build is
that green light on the top left corner
really so we're trying to really you
know try to of break this trade-off
right break just try to draw a new curve
is that we're trying to give you a
platform that's able to connect in your
operations data with you know with very
very high level efficiency and with no
gaps right and then there's only really
made possible by the decentralized
systems like Boston they're actually
able and immutable on it lock so this is
roughly over building right we talked
about what all the stuff we were
building this is Ralphie what we're
building you have at the
you have the decentralized Niger
technology our tracks are blocking and
then you've got one layer up then you
have these you know hardware as well as
software brokers right so Vanessa you
can have harder assets they're uploading
information automatically signing them
and clean them into the blockchain and
on the right side then you have people
write using variety of you know very
commonly seen communication tools around
email or tax sort up right and then all
that gets you know log into the lock
screen right and then we provide a set
of functionalities to our application
right so cross application collaboration
audit logging you know automated or
manual classification of the messages
that you're trying to you're trying to
audit
visualization and key manage right so
all this goes to really address the two
problems that we're talking about right
number one easily capture and kibriya
unstructured operational data right get
that data from you know from the
unstructured sources that people are
used to using right don't force them to
learn a new piece of software new piece
of technology just get it from whatever
application they're currently using
which tends to be text and email right
the second is confidently and quickly
scale with minimize friction right you
have lots of confidence in the data
you're collecting because it's easily
editable right just you have lots of
confidence on this on the fact that it
was actually happen with provenance and
amiability guarantee right so what does
this useful who would ever want to use
something like this right so besides
stone the cases that we mentioned before
we create a several category so you know
enterprises that we think might benefit
from from this from this path right so
any enterprise that actually deal with
complex ecosystems and stakeholders
alright so we talked about you know
cross border acid leasing you know in in
a case of something like an electrical
distribution equipment manufacturer they
need to deal with you know upwards of 15
to 20 stakeholders for every single
project I think work right
getting agreements locking agreements
between these peoples
we complex and time-consuming so we
having a mutable allele are very helpful
right second dealing with enterprise
that deal with rapidly changing
processes in requirements right so for
example you know if you're a software
else or some company you know you're
constantly dealing with you know
changing requirements right the the
client signs and you know contract with
you in the beginning but you know
there's 200 changes coming down the road
right so lots of these micro agreements
happening you want to make sure to
minimize the potential for disputes
later on and not let almost always
potentially derail and overwhelm your
operations start um if your enterprise
that have distributed or transient
workforces right this goes into the core
of what we talked about which is
coordination problem right it's
difficult enough to give people singing
the same room to agree on something
imagine if everyone is all over the
place right you know all over the world
sitting there suffer rooms in different
time zones and imagine eighty percent of
whom are contractors that are with you
for only part of the day so that
coordination problem becomes the
nightmare you know without some sort of
audible on it off right so construction
subcontracting and you know quite
frankly today we have loss of knowledge
workers you know under this pandemic
right that will also benefit from this
type of right in the last category that
we encounter is any enterprise just in a
segment that's heavily regulated in a
regularity on it right so when you met a
medical informatics company in Japan for
example um they are you know they have
constipation records under systems which
they are they need to regularly share
with the insurance companies and
patients and hospitals right they also
get audited on a regular or quarterly
basis and every time every single time
to get audited it's just a nightmare for
them right it's prime consume meaning
you know there are mistakes made and you
know things don't match up that you can
make tons of phone calls for your
confirmations with your partner's about
what who shared what data with you went
right so if you get once again create
I love that will make this whole thing
much more smooth right that's much less
disruptive to their daily operations
okay so the last thing I'll talk about
is really just read that you know this
is really the tip of the iceberg that
were that we're looking at right so you
know with bossing technology with
something like a decentralized system
it's really it's really a way for people
to coordinate right with a minimal
amount of trust pre establish trust
right so the applications that we're
building right now right it's really
string by distributed work processes
that's what we're doing right now but
really the big problem that words can
you solve is to minimize and you know
maybe eliminate coordination costs right
imagine we do that then we can scale
unbelievably quickly without losing any
innovation without losing the innovative
spark right that that you know that a
company that grew from a start-up into a
into a multinational should of retain
right so this is being a journey and I
really hope to to see you know is the
centrai system technologies like
blocking make a major contribution in
space so that's three the end of my talk
if you guys have any questions happy to
answer them underneath any case the the
arcade example was interesting because
the are the arcade owner also has
another problem he have he or she hires
employees that he doesn't trust to empty
the point in the coin did so this also
solved so you also get auditing there
and in fact the Xander centers
McDonald's now where the in-store
deposit thing is actually owned by the
bank yeah don't spill slaw goes in and a
bank as responsibilities from that
moment on which is sort of weird
are signing the data that seems to solve
most of the problems as long as they
don't replace the signing module but the
society module says I've been in the car
three weeks
well it says 57 Chevy I know nothing
about before three weeks ago yes but but
the the problem with a lot of the
blockchain things is who manages the
chain and who pays the costs because
none of your customers want to be in
that business
won't you be in the business of managing
a blockchain yeah yeah anymore they
wanted to design microprocessors yeah
yeah yeah yeah so yeah so let me address
the things that you said so the very
interesting and you pointed out about
the employees because our customers
customer right which are the arcade
operators they only hobbies are key
machines you know we talked to that and
they said exactly what you said they
said we need the system to because every
single week we have numbers to put it up
from our like you know 30 regions across
to the specific geography and the
numbers always look weird right and if
everyone keeps having weird excuses no
every single day about why these numbers
look weird and over time it's very
difficult for them to you really expect
right because they don't feel like they
have a good working rapport with their
operations team so that's definitely a
problem that they run into with regards
to do with regards to the the chain
problem who's operating the chain right
so we are you know naturally we are big
believers for public bosses right so
there are arguments that could be made
that private chain sort of good sort of
gateway drug I suppose for enterprises
into understanding becoming familiar
eyes and comfortable with talking but
ultimately we think they're published
rings are prior to best solution because
it's superior in terms of security
guarantees so public ball chains are
once again supposed to
operated by a decentralized network of
operators across the world right that's
that's the ideal now thus far how many
networks have achieved that kind of
decentralization I was in very few even
something like Bitcoin you know lots of
notes but they're probably mostly
controlled by a few very large money
right probably similar with eutherian so
it is a difficult thing to achieve but
you know I I hope that later on we can
help to achieve that so the people that
are operating the nodes should be
disinterested parties right so that are
operating it because they're getting a
cut of the fees for operating this for
operating the system right how
cryptocurrency interesting factors into
that is debatable that once again the
market landscape is rapidly changing
what type of you know does
cryptocurrency necessary need you have a
pivotal role in the operations of a
public coffee the answer would be yes
today I'm not sure what another answer
will be yes ten years or twenty years
from now but it looks like
cryptocurrency in ecosystem is probably
the best way to guarantee shared
interest you know in that ecosystem so
well it's once again can answer your
question is that the customers that are
actually using our systems no I don't
think they would be interested in
operating a note once again there's too
much complexity for them so they would
be for example paying us typical
software as a service feast in which we
would then you know sort of purchase the
privilege of using this box chain and
paying to the system on their behalf
right but in fact it'd be yeah they're
not most likely not going to be our our
customers are probably most likely not
going to be interested in dealing with
anything close to box me notes
speaking of arcades I just remembered
the most lucrative lark aids in the
world oh geez
slot machines and the thing about a
casino is every person thinks that the
people he met he or she manages are
stealing yes every layer but so so you
know I'm a pit boss all all my people
are stealing if I'm running the pit all
the pit bosses are stealing you know
running a floor etc all the way up and
at the end of the day Steve Wynn says
everybody below me is stealing and so
that would seem to be yeah that's where
that are our partners are being RK
machines also mention that they thought
that was the very real opportunity so
they're they're all they're all Japanese
customers in Japan is supposedly
legalizing gambling this year in 2020 in
anticipation of the Olympics which I
guess according to providers has pushed
next year but there's a huge market and
that's being opened up in Japan
potential with all new machines yeah so
very interesting opportunity the but one
of these is that proof-of-work can't
work and proof of stake work doesn't
scale and proof of stake is interesting
it's subject to I don't know what the
official name is it what I call it a
curly attack where if I get I don't have
to get an eternity the coin owners I
just got have to get a majority of
people who are staking to agree to cheat
everybody else yes
yeah and
I'm not convinced us I'm not convinced
that's not possible
oh yeah so pretty sure everything's
possible once again it's just a matter
of how costly you want to make it and
how disinterested these parties are with
whatever agenda you know the mistake is
either the tokens are circular the
tokens that are circulating aren't
involved in the in the in the
verification yes yeah the people who
aren't using it who determine truth yes
so the more useful the token is more the
people who don't care about its validity
controlling it's a back it's backwards
how much the court need is sufficient to
it's like central bank right so in a
very beginning right you might want to
have a very high staking rate right
because yeah your ecosystem doesn't have
a lot of applications and yet and I'm
just once again this is not a
forward-looking statement on how were
structured are yeah but I just you know
maybe you want to you know have 90% of
it locked up in staking right right but
the tokens not being used yeah they're
not being used right but I'll be other
all it becomes untrustworthy you hope
that one day will be right so for
example you could have lots of if you
have lots of fun well okay so so there
there are several things here right so
the tokens really just exist to record
things right yes you and people for
staking it we're either looking at the
token as an asset right so the asset
that Ernie I'm sorry the the earning
power of the asset can be easily
securitized into something else which
they can trade it's just that you know
in terms of you know logging
capabilities they're still locked right
to trade it right to trade them the
proceeds that you know you go from right
but the but the yeah so if
does happen that you know very shoe
change the running Tain's problem
because there just aren't that many
applications but if it does happen that
literally the number of coins that you
have divided into the smallest unit
cannot support the amount of application
volume then it's time to take a vote and
least some of those things that are
being mistake right so with the
arithmetic is if it's ten you start off
with 90% staking which means the tokens
are useless if you're successful you get
to ten percents taking and now 6% can
steal from everybody else yeah it's a
bad idea do you have ten percents think
I mean that's just a little well right
but but but if you okay I can change the
number to twenty percent if if you're
successful that number has to go it has
to go down the more successful you are
the body can go down that much right
because then you run into a problem
where a tiny percentage of right so the
more successful you are the more
vulnerable you are yes backwards well
you want to make well okay so faking is
that's once again is one form of both
guarantees there are also other ways of
doing it without staking you can just
not have staking and in who runs the
node who have who holds all the coins in
your wallet at the time of voting can
vote that's that's that's taken well no
staking okay staking usually involves
you locking your coins for an extended
period of time
a minor coin a minor has or controls is
a stake whether regardless what label it
is if the minors assets determine the
thing determine voting then
the more that the miners aren't owning
all the tokens the more control the
miners have with a small number of
tokens so well also I mean if you are
buying up a lot of the tokens or you're
then you know the hope is that you now
have a quota hosts taking the fact that
you sometimes don't go 2-0 I do because
I want to leverage my 3% to steal the
other 97% I'm buying to steal I'm not
buying - nah we're not what so it's once
again it's obviously a bad idea right so
it's a bad idea to have so little amount
of tokens state right but again it's
this more successful you are more
vulnerable you are or you could just
make the tokens more divisible you can
also do you know that doesn't change it
what do you mean I mean we're talking
about like we're talking for about
percentages mm-hmm right I can
infinitely divide that in ten percent
right but it's still a percentage well
percentages from being same right
because what is forcibly introduced more
supply is that you're running out of the
money in the dirty basically you're
saying that now so much that it cannot
be divided into paying something reasons
not at all what I'm saying
Oh 100% no matter how you divide it
there's a hundred percent yes there's
not a hundred and one there's not 99
yeah no matter what you do there's only
a hundred percent and if 90 percent is
off doing work and 10 percent is
allocated to doing verification I only
have to own 6 percent to control the 94
percent right but you wouldn't ever
write 6 percent yeah I have to not be
using my six percent to do work I have
to be using my six percent to do
validation if I own the six percent
that's being used validation I can steal
the other 94 percent
because I own 6% I was 60% of the vote
in stock because the other 94% the other
90% is out doing work yeah but you can
just make a requirement in the network
that you have a very high quorum
requirement right and these cards are
useless any given time well you know 75%
of it has to be voting instinct right
yeah which means which is which is lack
of success
it's like saying your bank has to have
90 percent of the money in the bank
there's no money out wait the point has
two roles here right I mean that's
that's the problem it's a it's a it's an
asset it's a it's a revenue earning
asset that gives you voting rights the
other word because is to access a ledger
to to pay fees right yeah and so 60
percent is on is used for validation I
caused inflation when I move it out into
the world or deflation one of the two
yeah very careful so there's no rights
taking right this is my claim well I
have me once again you go to get right I
don't know that anyone has gone you're
right she stopped you I keep
experimenting right yeah it's going to
be interesting there's going to be new
forms of crime yay
well I'm not so sure any that is doing
any new forms of crime is the experience
with the with Bitcoin was any example it
was pretty pretty much collusion and
ownership acquisition through collusion
new ways to write there's only 13
stories in the world we can we named the
character Han instead of Hans and
suddenly it's a four billion dollar
business
good bait could be in any case this is
this is a very nice system that you put
together Stephen it seems like a way to
make Bitcoin or rather blockchain
technology accessible and usable in a
reasonable way and that seems to be
something that's definitely a desire of
the marketplace at the moment mm-hmm
cool okay Thank You Dennis
Thank You Eddie